قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
تواصل هجماتها بالطائرات والمروحيات من
محاور عده فيزا بروجي باتجاه جنوبا كما
بثت استخبارات الاوكرانيه صورا قالت انها
لعمليه نفذتها وحدات اوكرانيه خاصه
واستهدفت منصات صاروخيه للدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه في منطقه لوجان كما اثرت
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه بان وحده اوميجا
الخاصه دمرت ثلاثه اليات لوحده دفاع جويه
روسيه باستخدام مسيرات قربى متينه
نهايه الشهر الماضي
معنى من موسكو مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
الدغير ومعنى منكيف مراسل الجزيره ايهاب
العقده وابدا بك ايهاب وما اعلنه
الاوكرانيون عن تطوير صواريخهم ومدى
صواريخهم لتصل الى 1500 كيلو متر وقد
استخدمت هذه الصواريخ في احدى الهجمات
اليوم
القوات الاوكرانيه وايضا السلطات
الاوكرانيه تريد بناء ترسانه عسكريه قادره
على الوصول الى الاراضي الروسيه والى عمق
المناطق الاستراتيجيه التي تستخدمها روسيا
لنقل العتاد وتخزين الذخائر والانطلاق
الهجمات الجويه منها على المواقع
الاوكرانيه لذلك فان اوكرانيا قامت بهجمات
بالمسيرات التي باتت قائمه
وتستخدم بكثافه في الهجمات ليس فقط على
المنطقه الاستراتيجيه القريبه من مناطق
القتال وانما الى العمق الروسي والى موسكو
وعدد من المناطق الاخرى الاعلان عن مساله
الاطلاق الصاروخ الاوكراني في ايطاليا
التجارب ياتي ذلك في مقاله هو السلطات
الاوكرانيه انه جزء من برنامج صاروخي كانت
بدات اوكرانيا عام 2020 لكن الواضح ان
اوكرانيا تريد استخدام هذه
الاسلحه البعيده المدى لارباك الوضع
العسكري الداخلي في روسيا وفي المناطق
الاستراتيجيه المهمه وهي كذلك تستخدم هذا
الامر بالتوازي مع عمليات عسكريه داخل
خطوط او خلف خطوط المواجهه في منطقه
وايضا داخل الحدود الروسيه لذلك جاء اليوم
الاعلان عن تدمير مجموعه مجموعه مضاده
للصواريخ والطائرات داخل
وسبقها اعلان عن هجمات لاحد المطاع على
احد المطارات الروسيه وايضا الهجمات
باتجاه جسر القرم جسر القرم بالنسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه هو جسر حيوي تستخدمه
القوات الروسيه وتقوم بتدعيمه في هذه
المرحله لمنع وقوع هجمات اوكرانيه عليه
لذلك استهدف بثلاث السيارات مائيه
قصفت هذا الجسر وان كانت روسيا تحدثت عن
انها دمرت هذه المسيرات قبل وصولها الى
اهدافها لكنها اوكرانيا تعتبر ان جسر
القرم ايضا منطقه عبور اساسيه للقوات
الروسيه باتجاه الجبهه الاساسيه التي
يتركز الهجوم المضاد فيها وهي المنطقه
الجنوبيه التي قال اليوم الرئيس الاوكراني
ان قواته تحقق تقدما دون ان يحدد طبيعه
هذا التقدم على طول خط